joining us now for more on this oklahoma
republican senator james lankford he's a
member of the homeland and governmental
affairs committee finance committee as
well and you've made a number of trips
to the border
you've described it as an epidemic it's
about to get worse is it not with this
title 4 42 relaxation it is title 42 was
always intended to be temporary but when
the bite administration came in they've
had a year to be able to establish
what's next and in that year they've
just basically worked on a plan to move
people into the interior faster they're
talking about how do i pick people up
here at the border and move them into
the interior so there's not chaos at the
border instead of working on a plan of
how to be able to stop it and turn it
around they're talking about how to be
able to move it and and strange as is
they're saying that the pandemic's over
at the border but members of the
military are still being forced into
retirement if they don't get the
covenant shot we still are wearing mass
on planes and the administration's still
requiring that so they're picking and
choosing where the pandemic's over why
why do they not think that this is a
crisis if they thought it was a crisis
they would stop it would they not they
should stop it and can stop it they have
the capability just the most basic of
things they need to have whoever gets in
for the last person in is the first
person up for a hearing and send the
message to people if you cross our
border illegally yes we're going to put
you in a trial and then we're going to
do it right now right now when you cross
the border you're given a piece of paper
you're asked where would you like to go
in the country for your hearing and then
they're given a piece of paper to go to
court in that spot six years in the
future six years they're allowed to stay
in the country if you do that you're
sending a signal to the rest of the
world come to the united states you can
be here for at least six years illegally
and we'll allow you that's a that's a
mistake we have no idea who these people
are i mean they're coming not just from
guatemala honduras they're coming from
all over the world that's correct and
the bite administration continues to say
we're talking about root causes of
migration coming in and they focus in on
what's happening in the northern
triangle but we've had people from all
over the world in fact last year we had
every single country in the world that
illegally crossed our border this year
we've had over 150 different countries
just this year crossing the border and
so you've got people coming in illegally
from every country that you can name so
this is not about root causes this is
about facilitating illegal trafficking
in the united states and every one of
those people is paying between four
thousand and thirty thousand dollars to
the cartels in mexico to be able to
cross the border so this is about ten
billion dollars to the cartels in mexico
just last year in moving people
illegally so we're enriching the cartels
and we're devastating our country right
now doesn't this also um hold down the
wages of of american workers i mean if
you bring in millions and we've allowed
in millions of illegal workers right now
illegal immigrants
doesn't it essentially keep prices low
on the wage scale it does actually and
you've got people competing that know
they can't go compete for wages and get
equal wages because they're here
illegally present someone can just say
well if you have a problem with what i'm
paying you i'm just going to turn you in
on that problem the other issue is the
cartel sometimes if you can't pay the
cartels they'll say well good we've got
something you can do for us to be able
to pay that off whether it's sex
trafficking drug trafficking whether
it's working in a sweatshop somewhere
here in the united states that is
managed by the cartels they have ways
that quoting what they can pay off their
debt as well that's also dramatic so
literally this is facilitating illegal
activity and hurting our economy and
people the vice president is supposed to
be in charge of the border it's part of
her portfolio
again there doesn't seem to be anybody
uh trying to get their arms around this
this crisis there's not you wait people
forget that when biden was vice
president he was also assigned to be
able to manage root causes of migration
he was also the one going down to
central america so literally he becomes
president passes that off to his vice
president we're seeing the same quality
of job being done now as when he was
vice president as well they're they're
not dealing with this and the people in
central america that i've met with the
leadership there they say it over and
over again stop encouraging people to
come to the united states by having an
open border because their labor force is
leaving which is hurting their economy
in their country and saying that what's
the what president biden is doing now is
encouraging people to leave their
economy come to our economy it's hurting
our nation and it's hurting theirs you
think the white house doesn't want to
stop the problem because that would be
seen as sort of endorsing some of what
president trump did
everything that the biden administration
is doing right now is to placate the
left uh the far far far left whether it
is environmental policy cutting off
what's happening with oil and gas the
united states saying we'll buy from
russia or venezuela instead of the
united states or whether it's the
migration issues that are happening
right now they're terrified of the far
left progressives who are open border
folks and just say open the borders
anytime they enforce the border their
far left starts screaming they kowtow to
them and it just gets worse let's talk
about uh judge catanji brown jackson the
vote likely to be this week in the
united states senate
what's your vote i'll be voting no there
will be several procedural votes that'll
happen as soon as tomorrow so monday
tuesday and then thursday the final vote
could be thursday she and i met on
thursday i've had a long meeting and
she's very pleasant to talk to she's
someone you would enjoy sitting down to
dinner with but someone i can't support
to be able to be on the supreme court is
a lifetime appointment we have
disagreements on the role of the
executive branch the judicial branch on
sentencing requirements and several
other issues on this but again she's a
pleasant person ken can't negate that at
all but it's this is a very serious
issue when you talk about how you're
going to interpret the law how the law
is going to be applied but it does seem
that i mean if you if you get every
democrat vote uh she is going to win an
appointment and and in fact there are
there's at least one republican senator
who has said she will vote yes right at
this point every democrat votes then
she's actually put onto the court so
there's no way that we can stop it the
same way the democrats were very upset
at the three trump nominees that we
worked with the supreme court but
there's no way that they could stop
those three nominees as they work
through the process if every republican
voted for them which we did and so when
we put those individuals on the court
then they're on the court this will be
the same as what they're dealing with as
well this is why elections matter
the um it doesn't change the
ideological balance of the court really
if if judge breyer on the liberal side
um
she's going to vote pride premier uh
primarily the same way he has would you
would you not say i would assume that
she actually clerked for judge breyer
and so she's actually been mentored by
him if you can say it that way and had
the opportunity to be able to serve
she's had great experience and
background all those things but every
expectation is based on how she's
handling sentencing how she's handled
the law and working with judge briar
that she'll be actually making decisions
very consistent with that same
left-leaning perspective
oklahoma senator james lankford we
appreciate you coming in tonight thanks
good to see you thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else